alors loin de la vague verte pour
l'instant l'équipe d'Irlande se fait
donc discrète mais l'engouement ne
devrait pas tarder à pointer le bout de
son nez un grand programme autour du
rugby est prévu en Touraine dans les
prochaines semaines Florent Clavel nous
le détaille le premier enfant des
rugbyman irlandais chez nous et bien
c'est ici ce samedi au stade de la
Vallée du Cher avec un entraînement
public vous l'entendez peut-être
derrière moi les agents de la ville
apportent la touche finale pour que
Jonathan sextone et ses coéquipiers nous
offre les plus beaux drops c'est là
aussi que le 15 du Trèfle donnera sa
toute première conférence de presse en
bref une grande fête en perspective
comme le souligne Bertrand Bourgeaud il
est l'un des grands artisans de
l'événement cette fois on y est pour
nous c'est le grand bonheur il y a
exactement près de 12000 places qui ont
été dispatchées par la ville dans les
clubs du département allez irlandais
vont vraiment être surpris quand ils
vont arriver dans cette dans ce chaudron
il va falloir les accueillir pour les
jeunes ça va être énorme et tout
différence photo séance dédicace et tout
je scrute un peu le ciel parce que je
croise les doigts faudrait que le soleil
soit de la partie parce que s'il pleut
mais n'en parlons pas dans la foulée de
leur entraînement les Irlandais
prendront la direction du grand théâtre
ou une cérémonie d'accueil les attend
avec une remise de médaille de la ville
ensuite et bien les choses sérieuses
vont commencer quatre matchs en un mois
le premier le 9 septembre face à la
Roumanie ensuite contre le Tonga puis
les chocs face à l'Afrique du Sud et les
cosses des matchs qui auront lieu tous
les samedis à Nantes Bordeaux ainsi
qu'au stade de France entre-temps et
bien les joueurs s'entraîneront trois
jours par semaine les lundi mardi et
mercredi à Tours à l'abri des regards au
stade de la chambreerie c'est là aussi
qu'il donneront toutes leurs conférences
de presse d'avant match devant la presse
internationale le 15 du Trèfle restera
en Touraine jusqu'à début octobre et
leur match contre l'Écosse à partir des
quarts de finale cette fois elle
rejoindront la région parisienne où se
déroulera la suite de la compétition
et pour que la fête soit plus folle les
organisateurs de l'entraînement public
vous invite à venir tous vêtus de verre